this is a production of Cornell
University
actually I should go back a little
further as you'll soon hear while I'm
talking that we Alan and I pronounce
about the same way which gives an
indication that I'm also connected it's
moved south not as far south as he but I
went through the university of guelph on
my undergraduate then came South here to
Cornell for masters in PhD and
eventually came back 1979 to join the
faculty here so no stuck around ever
since but it's a fun journey and I'm
gonna be pulling up stakes at the end of
September so it's been fun being part of
this but today I want to share with you
my latest love and that is high tunnels
cut flowers and things along those lines
so if all these gadgets work the topics
I want to cover and I'll hit the first
ones in fairly rapid order is what's
what our high tunnels I know our
audience is diverse so we need to go
into little detail there then focus in
on New York State what our high tunnels
used for here in the state then we'll
switch over to cut flowers again
assuming that some of you may not be all
that informed about that topic
you heard the about world wide cut
flowers are not necessarily coming from
our local areas but then within us and
again locally New York we want to know
about that and then we'll combine the
two major topics into high tunnels and
cut flowers and how we might use those
structures together first of all we need
a definition and this is a fairly loose
one it's an unheated plastic covered
greenhouse can be made out of metal or
most likely is or sometimes wood etc the
heat is provided by the Sun so those of
you in sunny locations will have a
better
time with these structures and those are
not and you do need to provide water
since these plastic sheds the water off
the US and New York State are quite slow
in taking on this technology it probably
started originally when plastic film was
discovered in the 1960s or so the asians
have taken this to a tremendous degree
as you can see from the acreages
involved 2.5 million acres those of you
that have traveled to China recently you
travel through the countryside on their
super roads and you look out the side
window and you see these valleys you
can't see soil it's all just plastic
after plastic after plastic and it's
mostly tunnels that might be as high as
as two feet or so this is a picture I
think that bill Miller's yeah but that's
you know the whole valley the whole
valley is covered with plastic and
they're growing vegetables primarily in
there they've also innovated they're
using the Sun as a heat storage device
or using the structure as a heat storage
device and these special tunnels in the
middle picture there are I have a north
wall that is made out of brick or earth
or something like that and the Sun comes
up and beams in there
warms that up in that night it radiates
the heat back so you don't need to heat
to place it but you do need sunny winter
conditions which in New York State is a
bit of a challenge of course so it might
not work here or if you fly over the
Mediterranean southern Spain Italy
Turkey Greece North Africa into Egypt
Tunisia etc all along the Mediterranean
there's tunnels all over the place and
this is al meriya Spain the picture on
the right it's
the plastic is covering everything so
tunnels were attacked and tunnels in
other countries are much more popular
and much more pervasive than here
350,000 acres in the Mediterranean
that's a lot of plastic that's a lot of
area covered okay so let's come closer
to home I'm sorry I didn't put in
pictures of gigantic tunnels and multi
structures and so on but just to give
you an idea that we've got quite a few
of these structures around these days
it's estimated between 500 and 600 farms
here in New York State have some kind of
protective structures most of which
would be high tunnels of various sizes
and shapes so they are becoming much
more popular here as well so why are
they becoming popular here well part of
it is a cost factor as you can see in
the table for a 30 by 96 foot structure
a high tunnel will cost you about 3 $3
in the corridor per square foot if you
move it it's costs more if you don't
want to be growing in the soil there you
want to move it to another place then
it's it has to be more rigid you need
the rails etc so it costs more by the
time you get to greenhouses we're up at
five six seven eight dollars per square
foot so it's a cheap alternative to grow
stuff in these in this information I got
from the remote catalog the other major
factors but given a big boost to high
tunnels and high tunnel production is
the USDA the NRCS has had for years and
it's still continuing in each of the
states a program by which they will
financial give financial aid for
construction of a new tunnel and if you
don't want a 30 by 72 foot one you can
get a 30 by 96 or larger size but they
will only pay for this that portion of
it but
it's been a quite handy boost for people
who are kind of on defense and say yeah
we could really use one but I can't
afford it well here's the way you can so
NRCS offices around the state can help
you with the applications for that and
so what is as I've already mentioned
we've we've had quite an increase in
high tunnels in New York State with at
this point and it's about a six million
dollar production value being grown in
these structures so what sorts of things
are being growing well we've heard about
Tomatoes earlier today and that's the
new the huge number one crop that is
very well adapted to tomato production
and it's if you're familiar with tomato
production and greenhouses the
production in high tunnels is quite
similar it gives the advantage just
having that Sun assist of having a
growing season that with a harvest from
mid late June all the way into October
is high quality because the rain is kept
off all these nasty diseases at Martin
Marjory mentioned are not altogether
gone but certainly much less problem
because you've got a dry environment in
there and you're applying water not to
the foliage but just to the ground okay
and you know 15 pounds per plant are you
pretty good and a lot of people have
figured that out and a lot of people are
doing it and you talk to growers and say
yeah I'd never produce a tomato outside
anymore I can get five times as much
yield from from the high tunnel Tomatoes
okay so that's that's such a popular
crop that once you have a high tunnel
and say why would I grow anything else
it makes me so much money but then you
get into Marjorie's problems again say
well ok botrytis is coming in this
disease that disease insects that have
gotten adapted to that situation and so
we've got problems of succession
you really should be growing something
else in
space to break up the problems that are
going to happen one way you can do that
is put in greens that can even go over
winter and be harvested in an early
spring
some of these salad greens are quite
cold hardy you can freeze them stiff and
next they'll come back out of it and can
be harvested in they're delicious but
not too many people know about coma
Touma and so I mean so many things how
and so there is a bit of it there is a
bit of a consumer education project that
someone needs to undertake to take more
advantage of these very productive crops
cucumbers colored peppers they're all
good but economically more questionable
they aren't as productive as tomato
right you can produce a good quality
crop but so in terms of selecting
vegetables for this high tunnel
environment there are some principles
you need to follow well first of all
what can you sell then you need some if
you're going to use the fall through
spring season you need crops that are
adapted to that and in hot watt weather
ok tomatoes do pretty well as long as
you've got with ventilation but you
might investigate ok I'm near an urban
area we've got a lot of people from
Latin America they're really interested
in vegetable vegetable Y or the Asian
folks and so on so adapting to what can
be sold out of some of the more tropical
materials could be quite lucrative the
longer you can keep the crop in the
ground and keep harvesting the more
attractive it should be because you've
got a consumer base it is used to
getting that material from you or a
grocery store and you should be able to
make out better that way
and then of course you can utilize the
space by something climbing but you can
also hang stuff from the top so I'll
show you an example of that some work
that Neal has done on that raspberries
raspberries don't like to get rained on
and raspberries can be extremely
productive in a high tunnel environment
those of you that are coming this
afternoon to see our cut flower trials
over on Maple Avenue will see high
tunnel with blackberries and also with
the fall bearing raspberries that start
bearing in about two weeks or so and
will keep on going through October who
has raspberries in October in New York
State
hardly anybody but those raspberries
give them to a consumer and they can
keep them for a whole week they don't
melt down because they've been protected
so the diseases don't get into the fruit
so that's a very lucrative crop and it's
a perennial so you don't have to plant
it every year so something to consider
blackberries same sort of thing
very productive huge berries in fact I
can show you those this afternoon that's
work by dr. Marvin Fritz and his
assistants okay so bedding plants your
area
luckily Neal Matson has done a bunch of
work on that started in our tunnel over
and Maple Avenue but it's worked with
growers on this ton of information he
gave me 75 slides I elected not to use
them but he's sitting right down here so
you want to know about that just talk to
him and the bottom line that he
essentially after all the work that he's
done on it is don't use them on cold
sensitive crops but it's for bedding
plants finishing the bedding plants
before they're going into the earth
centers a high tunnel could be quite
useful but you have to choose wisely
which crops you're going to do
with if it's it could frost in early
spring mid-spring and you've got coleus
in there forget it it's it's gone and so
you have to be very careful on which
ones you do this with it's also if you
have a crop that you're going to be
shipping to a particular are you trying
to hit Mother's Day you know some years
we get a real cold spring and no amount
of tunnel protection without the sun
shining is gonna get you that crop to
flower before Mother's Day arrives and
so that's a bit of a risky thing so not
having that deadline can can help and
you can use low tunnels and of course
nobody there's we don't have a high
tunnel police it comes around says you
said you have a high tunnel you don't
you putting supplementary Heat you're
not allowed to do that there's no such
thing if you want to put a heater in
there and keep things protected you
certainly can and so there is
flexibility there and in some situations
if it might make a lot of sense to have
a supplementary here during for those
cold periods to bring things are long
and it would still be a lot cheaper than
constructing a greenhouse with all the
bells and whistles that go with that ok
so here's some data that Neel shared for
one of the years the 9th in 2011 you had
a number of different bedding plant
species that he put in there in April
and the flower date in the greenhouses
so he had these parallel experiments one
in greenhouse and one in the high tunnel
and you can make the comparison the
greenhouse angelonia flowered on May 3rd
the high tunnel
well sorry did quite make it because
they did have frost events but if you
won't go to dianthus May 21 the
greenhouse May 29 in the high tunnels
not too bad
geranium almost the same time low below
your bed late and so on down the list
comes back to the point I was making
earlier okay so choose of species you
might do quite well nearly this set of
experiments with judge Reed Judson
reduced our high tunnel greenhouse
specialist for the state of New York
more lessees over in Penn Yan but is
available for advice for other parts of
the state of of course as well and so
they were putting I think petunia right
in hanging baskets about a tomato crop
and shade they had are we got having a
problem here
diem free of course yes of course
TMP free indeed it's just an example you
could you could put other hanging basket
type stuff in it yeah so so anyway the
bottom line on this one is both craft
came through fine none of them were
diseased and the yield of the tomato was
not affected by the hanging basket yes
it is warmer in time yeah during the day
uh-huh at night the temperature is
pretty much the same yeah okay
so now we're going into cut flowers
remember I was going to talk about cut
flower so okay here the cut flowers
about 15 years ago if you went to a
place to get cut flowers you probably
couldn't get much in the way of cut
flowers in a grocery store or a
supermarket but you had to go to a
florist right and what flowers could you
get well roses sure no problem
and chrysanthemums yep any time of the
year and also I had carnations yes and
so on and that was pretty much it except
in the spring you could get some
tulips and slowly isn't so on but
domestic production was pretty much
minimal advance to more recent times and
we still have the florists and even the
grocery stores are now even much more of
the grocery stores selling those for cut
flower species any time of the year very
reliable good varieties last life yeah
not too bad so but those are almost all
coming from here in this country from
South America if you're living in Europe
then it's coming more from Africa but
domestic production is really very very
minimal but we've come a long way since
then and people have started to demand
flowers locally we want something
different we'd like to try something
else and as a result of that that has
generated a very large industry that is
producing crops like tulips
Gerber's lilies gladiola irises etc etc
etc okay so the industry has changed
vastly over the last few years the South
American production mom's on the Left I
don't know what's on bottom right
interestingly enough they're growing
them in high tunnels but in upland
valleys where the temperature is the
same all year round the day length is
the same and they keep on producing and
the labor is cheap and the flowers are
flown overnight to Miami and then
distribute it all over the country so
you know what's not to like about that
it's very reliable in US consumers here
like that pretty well as well but you
know we have gotten into the flower the
cut flower deal here in the States and
we can see the kind of species that are
being grown
and their production values in the table
here and you know it's it's pretty
substantial but it's still it was the
big four are still the dominant flowers
and it's we're never gonna do away with
that and that's fine you know if you
want to get married in February you're
not going to go to your local flora or
to your local producer or flowers and
say hey where am I where my tulips are
roses we don't have them so so that's
always going to be but we do have this
very substantial production now of cut
flowers that is produced in the States
or even more locally so to give you a
little taste of where and what
large-scale production of flowers still
is primarily in western United States
back a hundred years ago it was Long
Island New York Pennsylvania New Jersey
etc and then it migrated out west
because it's easier to grow stuff out
there and now it's in specialized places
where the climate is ideal so the things
like hydrangea you have these cool
mornings in the in Oregon every morning
is cool and cloudian hydrangea loves
that grows like fantastic or the calla
lilies on the right also seem to like
that kind of climate but it's
diversified much more than that
the picture of up at the top there fresh
tulips USA the gigantic greenhouse in
Virginia that produces tulips about nine
months of the year and its production
it's industrial production they bring
the tulips in from the bulbs in from
Holland
sometimes a year other times the years
coming from Chile and they put them in
their storage rooms and give whatever
cold treatments needed and then they
bring them out into these greenhouses
there's no soil it's all just in crates
and some of them are hydroponic some of
are in some kind of special mix and
they're producing millions of stems that
are distributed you get them in your in
your supermarket you know six dollars
for a dozen and nobody can compete with
that and like it it's very nice so
that's it that's an example of the sort
of thing the other one is is not exactly
a cut flower production area but the
swamp Swan Island alias it's primarily a
propagation of the delegates but they
have so many varieties and they do sell
some cuts from there as well whatever
guy then parts of California again have
just the ideal climate for one species
or another and you see large-scale
outdoor production with very successful
but with the problems that they're
having with water these days who knows
it might not last that much although
this can compete with some of the other
things like alfalfa that they're growing
with that precious water this would be a
more lucrative crop I would think okay
so let's get back to New York State we
do have some large-scale producers in
fact within an hour's drive of here
we've got some quite substantial peony
producers up in the Geneva area that
produce peony cut stems and send them
down to New York Washington etc also on
Long Island the industry is coming back
to some extent larger scale again
because the proximity of consumers down
in that part of the state dahlias cleome
etc etc so quite a bit of production
coming back but what's more prevalent to
and perhaps more familiar to you all is
the small scale producer it has cut
flowers as a part of a larger maybe
vegetable operation or someone that's
just doing a you know a few hundred
square feet or eight
two acres of cut flowers that they then
locally take to the farmers market or to
grocery stores etc and the the the nice
thing about this whole trade is that it
is such a vast number of species that
are potentially used for cut flowers or
cut stems or cut foliage woodies etc etc
and we're very privileged to have the
authors of the Bible of this kind of
work with us in the audience you heard
from one already the man with the abouts
and the second one is Judy Lauchlan
who's sitting in in the back here to the
executive director of an organization
I'm going to mention a little later on
so they wrote the book there are 83
species in there vastra in there have
been others discovered quote unquote
since then so the list is even longer
but that's part of the fun of working in
cut flowers listed you saying hey we
could use that for cuts maybe so just
some scenes from local producers in
their beds of same years oftentimes part
of a tour where we're going to visit
them and and see what they were doing
so our production locally then is local
seasonal many species it avoids the big
four because we can't compete really
very well with that and the emphasis is
on quality and it's also these species
don't ship very well oftentimes but fine
you put a bouquet together you take it
home you put it in the Vaz you at least
should have it for a week okay and then
what did they do with them well I've
already mentioned it to some extent
farmers markets probably the largest
outlet supermarkets weddings roadside
stands the summit extent working with
restaurants and bouquet or other
businesses
that value fresh flowers have a
subscription service and then finally
we're getting to the high tunnel as a
place to grow these things and they're
very suitable the high tunnel structure
is well suited for producing high
quality flowers because you can grow a
lot in a small space the tunnels
themselves are valuable real estate so
the more you can pack in there the
better and if you choose the species
that can be harvested over a period of
time it allows you to have quite a nice
income so an extended growing season
because you're protecting against frost
in the spring you're protecting against
cold weather in the fall you're
protecting against wind which allows the
plants to grow taller and straighter and
you have the disease reduced because of
the drier environment inside and the
high tunnel environment is so near of
that of a greenhouse that you can use
all the tricks that John Sanderson would
tell us about in terms of natural
enemies to keep things like aphids
thrips the white flies and set are under
control so it does allow us quite a bit
of control methods that outside in the
field we are not able to use now it
isn't all rosy
and I would paint a wrong picture if I
didn't mention also this quite personal
picture on the left one does get snow
events and one does need to be ready for
it in that particular time we weren't
ready
we disregarded the manufacturer's
warning don't keep the cover on over
winter and we've gotten away with it for
two or three years and then I got a
phone call from the farm manager on my
birthday February 26 he said Chris I've
got some bad news for you yeah what Oh
your tunnel collapse and there are
places in this in this world where high
winds can occur this is Long Island
Experiment Station yeah where if you
don't have your plastic really pin down
well you can end up with shreds of
plastic all over the place and so high
winds can be a problem and up and do
require a special construction
techniques we have not a since not had a
problem we've kept the plastic on our
high tunnel for the last that was 2010
so the last five years without any
problem even though we did have snow and
the trick is to anticipate the snowfall
event and have a salamander heater
inside the structure to keep it warm
enough so that the snow slides off
instead of depositing itself well this
well this has a peak but it wasn't
enough of a peak and it was a wet heavy
snow that collapsed it down in that
regard so but there are ways to get
around that okay so what kind of things
already mentioned we need stuff of high
value we want a long harvest season we
want them early as possible and we want
high quality of the tunnel
so the crop over the top well let me
just go through high-value okay so how
much money can you make and we like to
compete against the tomato roars so we
say okay let's just put some of these
figures together and and a graduate
student and when Cayuga who some of you
I'm sure know put together this economic
analysis that took into consideration
the cost of building this structure as
well as what the income could be from
that and turned out that the lisianthus
gave you an income of $2 per square foot
just not too bad a couple of years you
got that Tunnel paid for more then
sunflowers just a single crop of
sunflowers only gave you 14 cents well
you wouldn't just grow a single crop of
sunflowers you put in more stuff so and
then the tomatoes come in sort of in
between depending on this size and the
the cost of the structure about 40 down
to 60 cents or so and then cukes by
themselves just a single crop of cubes
forget it don't everything lose money
okay okay so what kind of stuff do we
grow in there well some people try
foolishly myself tried to see okay can
we really do tulips and I will say that
tulips have a nice strong stem and I'm
much nicer than the ones you get in the
grocery store but nevertheless you're
competing with a flood and it's really
hard unless you've got something very
special the other one that's that has
turned out to be quite interesting for
us is anemone and ranunculus and it uses
a deadtime in a high tunnel we we plant
the bulbs in mid-december in the tunnel
and we are finished harvesting by late
May June and they
produce beautiful stands and gorgeous
colors that's a really serious one that
that uses a time of the year that
otherwise the tunnel is not really very
productive for so that's one really to
watch other spring crops more
traditionally early season planted so
Larkspur or sweet peas Campania 'la
companion medium that just look
wonderful and but they won't be out
until about June or so out of the tunnel
spring spring planted Snapdragon works
pretty well
go disha stock again our spring crops
that would be of interest mentioned as
the antis already it has a beautiful
elegant flower and there's lots of
different varieties different colors
look enough like roses they don't have
the scent of roses not that watered
roses have much of a scent anyway but
this is a very productive and lucrative
crop as I mentioned already then yes
dahlias again snaps are things that grow
quite well in tunnels and have a high
quality celosia amaranth are really
tropical so they love the warmth of the
tunnel and get enormous size if you let
them lots of different varieties even
the ropey one that Alan was showing us
earlier and then extending the season
into the fall you can get a falls in
your crop and keep it protected against
the cooler conditions the Snapdragon
crop also does quite well in the fall
what we've normally done is more
recently is say okay sometimes our
snapdragons overwinter for us in the
garden so what about the protection
structure of a high tunnel can't we keep
that over winter so we've done some
experiments over the last two years
where we're sewing the crop
in June or July transplanting into the
tunnel getting a fall crop off but it
then instead of yanking it out you just
protect it with a low tunnel come back
in the spring and harvest again so
getting 20 that's even 30 stems per
plant on a 9 by 9 inch spacing it's
pretty good and those of you that are
coming this afternoon to see our work at
Maple Avenue in the tunnel will have a
chance to see the crop that's more than
a year old now and it's gotten to be a
pest afraid yeah invasive market and
then the other things that don't
necessarily have to be in a final
situation but ornamental kale ornamental
cabbage the varieties are grow tall can
make a nice crop the picture on the left
is from Vancouver area in British
Columbia how many I'm just about I'm
just like three slides away ok so we've
got all these species we've got all this
stuff you know all these things
some of us and others they want to get
into cut flowers but were they gonna get
the information well cut flower growers
are not so numerous yet that you can ask
Cooperative Extension of New York State
about growing this or that or the other
thing well luckily we have an
organization which covers that area
tremendously well and again I'm
privileged to announce to let you know
the two of the founding the founders of
this organization are here in your
audience again dr. Armitage before he
got on to other things he was a founder
and his graduate student and then is the
executive director of the Association of
cut flower growers Judy lachemann back
here and she has information and and
literature if you're interested in
getting into cut flowers I
strongly urge you to talk to her and get
that information the ASC FG also has a
wonderful website with lots of
information their quarterly magazine is
certainly worth reading annual meetings
are occurring in different parts we had
it on Long Island what was it six seven
years ago and regional meetings have
occurred here in Ithaca but also are
scattered around the next one is in
Virginia third week of September if some
of you would be interested there's a
listserv we can ask a question oh gosh I
having trouble with this Dahlia variety
can you tell me what might be wrong and
so somebody else writes back to say oh
yeah I had some same problem last year
this is what you need to do about it
and things like that very useful and
there's a national coordinated variety
trial primarily open annual species but
also into perennials and woody species
that the growers themselves participate
in and provide the information and the
website I've already mentioned and to
let you know this is the hottest
information just produce you know
there's a grow local movement and
there's a do local than local local
local local this is the membership
numbers of the ASC FG since 2009 and if
you don't think that local is real just
look at that okay and it's going up so
yeah most organizations are going down
this one is climbing and it's growers
helping each other sharing information
enjoying what they're doing and the
membership is what 70% female I think
probably and most of them are all of the
families left so what am I going to do I
really love flowers I'd like to do
something let me get into this okay and
then other information we've done some
stuff others as I've mentioned already
judge read Neal Madsen etc there are
high tunnel websites we have a high
tunnel web site here as well of course
the work we've done on cut flowers is in
the horticulture queen research page
every year of research that we've done
is on there and then there's books like
the Bible I mentioned earlier and the
flower farmer by Lynn Basinski is also
quite a useful piece of information and
that's all the time I have and thank you
for your attention
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu